der fall schockierte im oktober 2018
ganz deutschland in freiburg fielen
mindestens acht männer über eine
studentin her die sie zuvor mit ecstasy
und k -o -tropfen gefügig gemacht haben
sollen
drei stunden wurde das opfer in einem
gebüsch vor einer diskothek brutal
vergewaltigt die gerichtsverhandlung zur
aufarbeitung dieses grausamen verbrechen
wurde zu einem mammutprozess insgesamt
wurden elf männer angeklagt nach 45
verhandlungstagen und mehr als einem
jahr prozess soll heute das urteil
fallen
für uns hat sebastian dränge den prozess
am freiburger landgericht verfolgt und
ist mir nun auch live zugeschaltet
sebastian haben denn alle täter
ausgesagt haben sie sogar zugegeben an
der tat beteiligt gewesen zu sein
die täter haben die tat nicht gestanden
ich meine der prozess dauerte immerhin
13 monate das ist der viel zeit um hier
reinen tisch zu machen um diese
abscheuliche tat zu gestehen das haben
die täter nicht gemacht wir haben kein
geständnis keine reue es gibt keine
entschuldigung stattdessen haben die
angeklagten über ihre verteidiger
ausrichten lassen dass der
geschlechtsverkehr nicht nur
einvernehmlich gewesen sei sondern
vornehmen von den mädchen massiv
eingefordert wurde
man hat es so dargestellt als sei dieses
fast dreistündige martyrium ein
vergnügen für die junge frau gewesen und
das ist natürlich eine ungeheuerliche
behauptung das macht fassungslos das
macht wütend das ist einfach
ungeheuerlich so kann man sich gar nicht
vorstellen wie so etwas sein kann
heute soll das urteil fallen gegen alle
elf angeklagten oder weiß man bereits
wie viele von ihnen verurteilt werden
sollen
er hat drei angeklagten sind
mittlerweile wieder auf freiem fuß da
konnte der tatverdacht nicht
aufrechterhalten werden
da hat die staatsanwaltschaft einen
freispruch gefordert und zwei
verurteilungen wegen unterlassener
hilfeleistung bei den anderen acht
angeklagten ist die staatsanwaltschaft
sich sicher dass sie diese abscheuliche
tat begangen haben da sind
freiheitsstrafen in einem raum zwischen
22 jahren und zehn monaten und
fünfeinhalb jahren für den
hauptangeklagten gefordert wurden